Wooh!
Oh!
So a common problem when playing ArcherySoft
is that people don't always call their hits.
So having a reliable way
*laughs*
Having a reliable way to know that you hit somebody
would be rather effective
and a very reliable way would be a camera
in the end of the arrow.
We are going to try to mount a GoPro
to the end of the arrow.
Maybe I can hit Wren right now.
Ready?
yeah
*laughs*
*music*
*sounds of tape ripping and low conversation*
*stab stab stab*
Eugh!
*tape snapping, box hitting floor*
Oh, whoa!
What?
What's going on?
What are these?
What are these??
I don't know
Woaaaah!
*toy hits wall*
Oooooh!
What the heck?
I'm gonna try that one
That's so spooky
Woah!
*screams*
*screams again*
Somebody sent us an email
like a month ago
Xshot sent us an email like
Hey we make all these dart guns
and we're like that's cool
and they're like can we send you some?
and we're like, yea!
And that's that story.
*all laughing*
They do work
and they do work with our current nerf dart selection
They're not quite as high tech
but it'll be good to have around for when we need like
a couple extra single shots.
Give it a shot
Give it an Xshot
*plastic gun cocking*
Alright range test
Kind of like a hammershot
They hold a couple shots but they're single shot
Pretty accurate though
Yea not too bad
So let's get things started here.
Here's my GoPro
*crafting montage music*
Cool
Let's see if this carves it out at all
*dremel whining over montage music*
Nick, how have you been enjoying your time
working on the Sam and Niko channel?
What have you learned about vlog film making?
Is there a pro tip you can give to people watching the vlog
if they want to edit their own?
You know that's the biggest point of feedback I have for anybody
when they ask me to look at their work
is like, it's too long
cut cut cut.
Good rule of thumb when editing something and determining pacing is
say verbally what you're trying to convey on screen
"The character stands up and walks out of the room."
If the shot takes longer to do that
than it does for you to say what happens
the shot's too long.
What are you going to put in there?
GoPro
I mean ... smart if you have more than one.
It's just a matter of pulling this up on the outside
but I don't think we're going to get much out of that.
*beep*
Oops
We have these little floaties
This will slip over here
In an efficient manner
There we have it.
GoPro arrow mount
It works!
October is over
I'm still alive
I have a daughter
We shot everything that we needed to shoot
and the company didn't go under
*clicks tongue*
Tears of joy.
Feeling a lot better about November
than I was about October
Something that you guys never know
is that footage gets lost every now and then
We don't know how it happens
but when you shoot as much as we do and put out a new video every other day
Sometimes a scene that you shot a few days ago
just kind of disappears and no one knows where it went
One of those things is this gun right here
*pained sound*
A fan actually painted this gun
with the Corridor logo and sent it ...
*board clatters*
And what's cool is he also like
modified it so it's actually a stronger gun than normal
We wanted to give a cool shoutout to the guy who made this and stent it to us
If you're the one who actually sent this to us
please leave a comment on this video
and we'll be sure to send you something pretty cool
It might just be a nerf dart that we signed
It might be ... our entire raid server
Probably won't be that one
I don't know how well this is going to fly yet
I think it'll be ok.
It's going to be...
...great.
First test here we go. Ready?
Three, two, one
So the GoPro actually came out just a little bit
of its enclosure right there
Here we go!
Hey that was pretty good
I feel like the ultimate test
is to shoot it as high as it can possibly go
and to see it go up and arc and come back down.
There's a lot of cars around here
Then don't hit the cars
Okay!
Wren's going to try to catch it, if he doesn't then we might break the GoPro
So big stakes here
No pressure
Say goodbye to this GoPro
GoPro, I hope you make it back from this journey
You're the first one of your kind to ever go into space
*kissing sound*
Kiss, Wren
*omph*
Three, two
*whooshing*
Wooh!
Nicely done!
That was great!
Here we go! Three two one
Oh that was perfect!
Alright, Wren
Run
Run to your brother!
*augh!*
*laughs*
You got my elbow!
We got a little scuff on the GoPro
Oh teh noes!
Everybody on the Sam and Niko channel really appreciates what you do for us
*groans*
*groans in slow motion*
That actually really hurt
I have a numb thumb
Since I got to shoot at you a whole bunch
you may now shoot at me
*laughs*
That was a slap!
That was satisfying actually
When I was a camp counselor for five years of my life
we had archery
and I was the archery instructor for one summer
So I say that now, but I'm going to be terrible.
Do we have a... Do I... Is this right?
It's like a solid 40 feet
Really?
Maybe 50?
Here we go
That was like almost pretty close!
That was almost- That was not terrible
as my parents would say to me
growing up
Do you want to be shot at?
Yeah I'll be shot at
I do want to shoot him.
Remember that I love you.
I love you very much
My last words
are pepperoni.
That's what I want on my tombstone.
Ready?
Woah!
That was right at you!
Good catch!
Well that was my matrix dodge
The bumpers worked
It gracefully bounced down the street.
Thank you guys very much, that was nice of you.
Bye! Bye, CorridorDigital! Goodbye!
About to see the footage for the first time.
Sixty frames per second means you can actually do some slow motion
Woahh
That's really cool
Zooooooooooof
Look at that twist
So I'm manually twisting it at the opposite rate it spins
so you'll see the arrow spinning around the edge of the frame
but the world will stay flat
Oh that kind of creates a really cool effect
Yea it's really trippy
It was a success technically
But I would love to have like a more powerful arrow
on a more powerful bow
and shoot a GoPro even further.